plein minimum des marolles et à monsieur
gérald darmanin monsieur le président en
l'absence de monsieur premier lis ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la ville
permettez moi tout d'abord de vous dire
que c'est avec une certaine émotion que
je pose cette dernière question
remerciant mes collègues et
particulièrement aux présidents de
groupe christian jacob pour la liberté
la confiance qu'il m'a accordée pendant
ce mandat monsieur le ministre l'égalité
des chances est bien plus qu'un slogan
il doit être une politique je ne doute
pas de vos bonnes attentions monsieur le
ministre mais force est de constater que
l'effet contrarie largement vos
promesses l'égalité des chances en
premier lieu doit être au rendez vous
des enfants de la république dans ma
ville de tourcoing qui ressemble à tant
de villes ouvrières et populaires de
france
les enfants ont besoin d'interventions
de l'état des collectivités
territoriales pour établir cette égalité
des chances
nous venons d'apprendre monsieur le
ministre une décision incompréhensible
de votre ministère en effet le
dispositif de réussite éducative qui
permet aux enfants qui ont des
difficultés de langage et de vocabulaire
d'être soutenues par des aides
individuelles par l'éducation nationale
était jusqu'à présent financé par l'état
et voilà deux ans de plus en plus encore
cette année 40% que les collectivités
territoriales doivent se consacrer
entièrement leur budget à deux au
désengagement de l'état quatre cent
mille euros pour la ville de tourcoing
rien que cette année pour une ville qui
connaît déjà les 2 millions d'euros de
charges supplémentaires décidé par les
rythmes scolaires de votre gouvernement
les deux cent mille euros de moins pour
son conservatoire de musique populaire
et malheureusement je obligé de le
constater et 5 millions d'euros de
baisses de dotations pour durant le
mandat de françois hollande c'est
inacceptable d'autant plus inacceptables
monsieur le ministre que c'est une ville
où 22 % des élèves du collège ont un
retard d'un an et 27 % des 15 17 ans
n'ont pas de diplôme
alors monsieur ministre arrêté les
exercices comptables et des vraiment
l'égalité des chances et des vraiment
nos enfants des quartiers populaires
merci la parole est un monsieur patrick
kanner ministre de la ville d'agen place
et des sports
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
darmanin pour votre dernière question
j'aurais aimé qu'elles soient plus
précises en termes d'augmentation
je voudrais vous répondre allez aller là
où tu es là répond réussite éducative
est une priorité absolue de notre
gouvernement
vous le savez la refondation de l'école
a été l'une des principales loire
aujourd'hui de ce quinquennat et le
département du nord avec 31 rep et 40 31
ans et plus et 46 rep dans le nord n'est
pas un département qui est sacrifiée
bien au contraire
en complément de toutes ces mesures
visant à assurer l'égalité des chances
par l'éducation
vous savez que nous avons développées
sanctuariser le programme de réussite
éducative dans les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville et le
département du nord est un département
prioritaires lui aussi en la matière
dans ce cadre monsieur darmanin je tiens
à vous confirmer que 77 millions d'euros
sont consacrés à cette politique
volontariste une politique volontariste
qui a d'ailleurs été instaurée par
l'anme les prédécesseurs que je tiens à
saluer monsieur jean louis borloo
ministre de la ville c'est un
gouvernement précédent dont seulement
nous préservons ces crédits non
seulement nous l'ex en quarts is on est
bien évidemment nous donnons des chances
supplémentaires aux villes qui sont les
plus concernés
je ne partage pas l'analyse qui est
celle que vous avez développé et que je
vous demande de bien vouloir m'expliquer
lors d'un entretien particulier si vous
voulez je n'ai pas cela les quartiers
prioritaires de la ville dans le nord
reste une priorité absolue je tiens à
vous signaler que dans les 437 contrat
de ville que nous avons signé
aujourd'hui les crédits sur l'éducation
reste une priorité pour notre
gouvernement donc monsieur darmana vous
êtes dans une logique que manifestement
de polémique je le regrette
et les tourquennois seront connaître la
vérité si la morale et à madame isabelle
atta